joining us now is the executive VP of
the Trump Organization Donald Trump jr.
there's a lot to decipher here what I'm
beginning to see is corruption a
compromised Adam Schiff a congenital
liar
now a non whistleblower Wow you're gone
it's it's just a continuation I mean we
all know that this impeachment inquiry
literally started on November 9th of
2016 whatever they could add in there to
create the narrative and honestly the
media is happily willing to sell it they
don't even pretend to be objective
anymore you saw that this weekend when
al-baghdadi the number one target on my
father's hit list the number one person
in Isis the worst human being on the
face of this earth is a mere austere
religious scholar not a terrorist not a
rapist
not someone that throws homosexuals off
of buildings he's an austere religious
scholar but Nick Sandman one of the
innocent fifteen-year-old kids from
Covington Catholic is a homegrown
terrorist the media is destroying their
credibility they're taking a what little
faith people had left in those
institutions and totally flushing it
down the toilet
you're seeing that with the media you're
seeing that with the left you've seen
that with Adam Schiff for the last three
years because again other than my father
no one was a bigger target of the
original Russia hoax now you have
version two than me and he's able to
alter emails he's able to leak this he's
able to change the narrative now you
have guys like Lee Zeldin that are out
there saying hey I'm in the room I this
is ridiculous when are you going to let
us speak when are you going to let us
ask a question you know I remember the
Washington Post making a big deal about
democracy dying in darkness yet they
have no problem with this going on for
three years
and certainly not for the last 40 days
of this sham in a dark room in a
basement of Congress impeachment
investigation where no one's even asking
the question about what's going on it's
a true disgrace Sean but the good thing
it's gone so far that the American
people get it it's gone so far that
those people even the people in the
middle even the people on the reasonable
left what's left of them because this is
no longer your grandfather's Democrat
Party anymore
these are extremists but the reasonable
people in the middle they get it they
want to see this president be able to do
their it's his job they want to see
Congress enact actual legislation to
benefit the American people u.s. MCAS
been sitting on that desk for nine
months Nancy Pelosi doesn't want to do
that because she doesn't want to give
Trump even a little bit of credit for
getting things done and this president
is getting things done for the American
people in an unprecedented fashion with
unprecedented incoming from the other
side
imagine look at all the media protects
Joe Biden Joe Biden is on tape and a
quid pro quo either you fire him in six
hours or you're not getting the billion
dollars that fire him you get the
billion dollars quid pro quo then you
got do you know anything about Ukraine
know anything about energy no oil no gas
nope
millions of dollars oh that was the guy
that Joe demanded to be fired imagine if
that was your name was hunter Biden
except I wish my name was hunter Biden I
could go abroad make millions off of my
father's presidency I'd be a really rich
guy it would be incredible but because
my name is Trump if I took one point
five dollars from China not 1.5 billion
like hunter but 1.5 dollars their heads
would explode if I took a no-show job
for eighty-three thousand dollars a
month for a business I knew nothing
about any language I didn't speak in a
corrupt country like the Ukraine where
my dad says we're gonna withhold
billions of taxpayer dollars if you
don't get rid of the prosecutor
investigating me the media would end
themselves Sean they'd have an aneurysm
we'd end the fake news media problem
that's the double standard that we're
living under right now and that's the
double standard that the American people
are sick and tired of I would say
they're all triggered but in
yeah I just said that on purpose bond
thank you for that it was